hey guys Dr Burke here listen in this
video I want to discuss how to dissolve
kidney stones but I want to make a
disclaimer first make sure that you're
discussing this information any changes
with your doctor because this is not
meant for replacement for any meds or
any surgery that they're going to do on
you okay so I just wanted to present
this as extra information to work with
he or she in helping to you know prevent
this from coming back or helping slow
down Stones sometimes it takes several
months to dissolve stones and if you can
prevent an invasive procedure I think
it's worth it to try this you can always
go back and get an ultrasound and see if
the stones are shrinking but here's
here's the data most kidney stones are
calcium oxalate stones or calcium
phosphate Stones 20% or a little less
than 20% of the stones are uric acid
crystal stones okay so there's two
different there's several but these are
the main two now gall stones are
completely different than kidney ston
Stones as far as the formation gall
stones are more cholesterol Stones
because of lack of bile kidney stones if
we're going to talk about the most
common are calcium oxalate Stones okay
so there's there's really two things
that you need to put your attention on
one is removing the oxalates from your
diet this is like a waste product from
metabolism but oxalates bind with
calcium in the kidney okay and they
develop these little crystals that then
can create a lot of problems they can
get lodged right on the kidney right
before the urer and cause a backup of
fluid and pressure and cause a lot of
pain the symptoms from kidney stones are
very similar to the symptoms from Gulf
Stones so sometimes you don't know what
is causing what um because they're very
very similar but you can get an
ultrasound or a CAT scan to find that
out all right so the underlying
mechanism is that um usually the person
is low in citrates and high in
oxalates now
citrates um actually help prevent the
formation of stones and help dissolve
Stones so the two
mechanisms that you want to focus on are
increasing citrates in the diet
decreasing oxalates all right so let's
go through step one number one you want
to increase citrates there are many um
types of um lemon juice that you can
consume I like the P of lemon juice uh
you can even get lemon juice any lemon
juice and it will work but I would like
to recommend that you get a higher
quality lemon juice because it's a lot
more nutritious volcano is the best but
you can just get organic lemon juice but
lemon juice has a lot of citrates any
any uh mineral with citrate at the end
of it is a citrate so you can do
potassium citrate which I like that one
way better than sodium citrate but
potassium citrate will break off so a
good portion of the potassium will go
this way and citrate will go that way
way and it starts to form with the
calcium and help break up the stones so
that will handle the citrate number two
you want to avoid oxalates now I put a
link down below of all the different
categories of foods and what has high
extremely high oxalates and what are
very low and you can use that but
spinach is at the top of the list
spinach has hundreds of uh M milligrams
of oxalates um per ounces of spinach and
then we also have um avocado is high
dates are high grapefruit is high potato
wheat beans beets are very high Swiss
Chard is very high kiwi canned pineapple
is very high figs and tofu are very high
in oxalates okay nuts unfortunately are
very high almonds are very very high I'm
sorry did you realize that that kale is
very low in oxalates even though it's a
cruciferous it has like 17 migs per 3 o
spinach is hundreds okay cabbage is low
in oxalates bok choy is low cauliflower
is low cucumber is low so take the list
down below dissect it make notes on what
you're going to you know do as far as
you're changing your diet now the point
I want to make is this it is true in
some of the other videos I talked about
calcium coming out of solution into the
different soft
tissues um when your body is too
alkaline okay so when you have alkalosis
calcium participates or precipitates out
of the solution and starts clogging up
joints and things um that's true but if
you take dietary calcium like some
cheese and things like that um that will
not end
up in the calcium through the kidneys in
fact fact some of that calcium to the
digestive system will bind with the
oxalates and lower the chance of getting
a stone the thing you need to worry
about is taking dietary extra calcium
like supplements like calcium in a
supplement form especially calcium
carbonate you want to avoid that so just
make sure you're not taking any
supplements with calcium but you can
take some dietary uh foods that are
higher in calcium
okay um the other point I want to make
is there's a confusion with vitamin D
there's mixed
reviews um a lot of the recent research
say says that vitamin D actually helps
lower uh Stones Some of the older
research says it will increase it but
here's my viewpoint vitamin D helps the
absorption of calcium in the intestines
by 20
times that doesn't necessarily mean it
ends up in the kidney okay so I think
it's okay uh vitamin K2 is another
vitamin that that's very important if
you have kidney stones because that
helps you hold calcium in the bone that
helps you remove calcium from soft
tissues and puts it in the bone where it
should be so this is a very good anti-
kidney stone vitamin there's also mixed
reviews in vitamin C or ascorbic acid
you know synthetic like large amounts of
ascorbic acid uh some uh studies show
that it increases some studies do not so
I am I don't have an opinion of vitamin
C I don't know exactly what it
does some people think that cranberry
helps uh dissolve kidney stones it does
not all cranberry will do will help
lessen the the stickiness of the
bacteria on your bladder okay now let's
talk about uric acid
crystals now that particular type of
stone usually comes when your pH is too
acid your urine pH is too acid and that
could happen after several things number
one you did a ketosis diet and all of a
sudden you with getting stone or you
have an insulin problem a lot of
diabetics have kidney
stones because of the sugar involved
because sugar fructose that kind of can
lead to uric acid building up in the
body so if you have more of the uric
acid Stones what you want to do is
increase the ph and you could do
that or alkalize the body a little bit
more by take the potassium citrate or
even lemon juice because both of these
are alkaline even though the lemon juice
is a an acid it turns into an alkaline
Ash in the body so actually these two
remedies will be good for both of these
the last point I want to mention that's
very very important is that if you have
a u acid crystals in the kidney their
little stones or gout you need to fix
the insulin you need to lower the
insulin okay because it usually comes
from insulin resistance I'm going to put
a link down below to give you the data I
just wanted a more of a
comprehensive video because I have a lot
of different videos talking about
different aspects but this is uh a real
comprehensive video just to give you the
overview of what to do if you had a
kidney stem all right thanks for
watching